Pourquoi tu as vu quand on a un angle comme ça, un grand angle, on a toujours envie de faire voir son pif comme ça ?
-Moi c'est l’œil plus.
-Ah oui c'est pas mal !
Ah tu sais quoi quand tu mets ta tête ça me rappelle... Comment il s'appelle ? Muller.
Il ne fallait pas l'inviter.
-Il ne fallait pas l'inviter, c'est ça.
-Il ne fallait pas l'inviter Guillaume, il ne fallait pas l'inviter.
Mais si, mais Guillaume, il m'a invité en plus c'est vrai tu m'as invité !
-Ouais !
-Je ne sais pas si tu es au courant d'ailleurs ! [rires]
-Non non, non non non !
-Ce mec là, m'a invité à venir voir son One Man Show improvisé ce soir et c'est super !
Et dire qu'à la base j'avais décidé de partir en lousdé à la fin, au cas où tu vois. Et...
-C'est vrai que tu t'étais mis au fond.
-Oui mais ça c'est parce qu'il y avait Raphaël Callendreau, le mec qu'on a vu hier dans la vidéo.
Ton nom de famille n'est jamais remis quelque part du coup je... je
-Darnault
-D'accord !
-Darnault qui est là et qui est repris là aussi
-Comme le metteur en scène ?!
-Oui
-C'est ouf en fait, la même famille.
-Ouais, on se connaît très bien.
-Hé hey !
Bon, je gagne du temps parce que je ne sais pas, je sais pas du tout ce que je veux faire pour mentaliser notre ami Guillaume.
-Hah !
-Du coup, je me dis, tu fais de l'impro mais j'ai déjà fait une vidéo avec un mec qui fait de l'impro récemment donc ça, ça m'embête...
[réfléchi]
-Ça, tu vas le couper au montage ? (Raphael)
-Oui, probablement ouais !
-Pourquoi ? C'est vachement intéressant !
-C'est hyper intéressant pourtant, je comprends pas !
-Qu'est ce que je vais faire ?
Pou, pou, pou, pou, pouh...
-En fait, dans ce spectacle là, à un moment donné, tu nous as parlé d'amour, de premières rencontres ou de chose comme ça
La manière dont c'est fait, me laisse à penser que, tu peux t'en reservir potentiellement de temps en temps,
parce que c'est pas un sketch, c'est juste de dire que des fois on rencontre quelqu'un pour la première fois.
-Oui
-Je ne spoile rien, ça va.
-Non, ça va.
Et bien on va partir la dessus, c'est à dire est ce que tu es marié toi actuellement ou est ce que tu es en couple ?
-Oui.
-Est-ce que ta femme est très jalouse si on parle d'une de tes ex ?
-De mes ex, non j'ai eu la chance de toujours tomber sur des filles pas jalouses, moi.
-C'est vrai, cool.
-Ça m'arrange bien, je vais reprendre un des endroits de ton spectacle,
J'aimerai que tu repenses à la première personne à qui tu as donné un bisou, un baiser.
-Ok.
-Tu peux le faire ça dans ta tête?
-Dans le spectacle ?
-Non dans la vie.
Dans la vie, dans ta vraie vie à toi.
-Ok, d'accord.
-Tu t'en souviens ou pas ?
-Ouais.
-D'accord. Tu as ce prénom là en tête, tu te souviens de cette personne ok. Tu avais quel âge environ ?
-Le premier... Moi j'étais sur du bisou avec la langue.
-Ah ouais pas mal, ok. J'avais... 4 ans
[rires]
-Voilà ! Non du coup j'avais 13.
-13 ans, d'accord, ok.
Super. 13 ans c'est pas mal ça me donne des indices sur la génération.
J'aimerai que tu fasses quelque chose, tu vas écrire le prénom de cette personne sur ce calepin. Tu déchires la feuille et tu la mets dans ta poche ou ici sous un flyer.
-D'accord.
-Donc tu écris le prénom lisiblement parce qu'après, à la fin, on va le faire voir à tout le monde.
Je te laisse faire ça, ici, comme ça vous aurez une preuve
tangible.
Tu fais ça.
Tu l'écris en majuscule, tu arraches la feuille et tu la mets dans ta poche pour le moment.
-Je ne la montre pas pour l'instant ?
-Non tu ne la montres pas
-Très bien.
Vous ne voyez rien !
-C'est bon c'est fait ?
-Oui c'est fait !
-Ok.
-Voilà, c'est dans ma poche !
-Super !
-Tiens
-Merci beaucoup.
Alors, Guillaume, que ce soit bien clair, tu viens d'écrire le prénom sur ce calepin.
-Oui.
-Tu as arraché la feuille et tu l'as mise là. Je n'ai pas pu voir la feuille, je n'ai pas regardé cet écran là.
-A priori non, non, non, non.
-Non, on est d'accord.
Raphael ne m'a pas fait des signes chelous pour...[rires]
-Non, non, non.
Enfin, il fait toujours des signes chelous, mais pas plus que d'habitude.
[rires]
-Je vais essayer de donner des éléments sur cette fille là, sur cette personne là, de quand tu avais 13 ans, et au fur et à mesure tu me diras si j'ai bon ou pas.
D'accord ?
-Oui.
-J'imagine que cette fille, elle avait les yeux... plutôt elle avait des yeux...
Ca c'est bon?
-Ouais ouais, ouais ouais !
-Parce que je ne me prive jamais d'une victoire.
-Non, non, elle en avait deux du coup.
-Elle en avait deux donc.. c'était une fille du sexe féminin ?
-Ouais.
-Donc pour l'instant on serait sur un sans faute?
-Ouais, là ouais !
-Tu aurais pu me dire "Non l'opération c'était bien passée..."
-Non non non non vraiment non. Tout est bon.
-D'origine féminin.
-Nickel.
-Ok.
-Vraiment, là je suis impressionné !
-Ok. Est-ce que tu peux penser à la dernière lettre de son prénom, s'il te plait ?
-Ouais.
-Et me donner ton poignet en même temps, et tu penses à la dernière lettre uniquement du prénom.
-Ça peut être: A, B, C, D, E, F, G, H, I, E?
-E ?
-Ouais.
-D'accord. Ok, c'est un E.
Pas mal. C'est... tu me réponds par oui ou par non mais que dans ta tête. D'accord ?
-Ok.
-Par exemple, dans son prénom il n'y a qu'une syllabe.
Ou il a 2 syllabes.
Ou il a 3 syllabes.
Ou il a 4 syllabes.
Ok.
D'accord c'est...
Elle avait 13 ans et toi tu avais quel âge?
28.
[rires]
Ah mer** ! Je ne voulais pas aborder ce sujet là du coup.
-C'était moi qui avait 13 ans. Elle, du coup, je pense qu'elle devait avoir dans ces eaux-là aussi. Donc je dirai 13.
-D'accord donc c'est de notre génération à nous. On est d'accord ?
-Oui.
-On était au dessus de 4 syllabes je pense.
Du coup, le prénom... Tu es de quelle région de France?
-C'est à haute voix ou pas ?
-Oui, ouais ouais.
[rires]
-Ile-de-France.
-Je ne vais te donner aucun indice.
Je te dit tout dans ma tête: oui, non !
[rires]
Bon, j'ai écris quelque chose là, je ne le fais pas voir, je ne vous le fait pas voir.
Par contre là, il y aura pas de cut. On va tout faire, pour pas que l'on pense que je change quelque chose.
Je te le montre à toi pour que tu vois que je ne change rien.
Est-ce que tu peux sortir le papier que tu as dans ta poche, avec le prénom de marquer ?
Il est au fond de ta poche !
-Oui !
Et on va le retourner à 3 mais en direction de l'objectif.
-Attends je le regarde si faut le retourner. Hop !
-C'est bon tu es prêt?
-Oui
3 !
-Caroline.
CAROLINE !
-Ho !
Comment c'est possible ?! (Raphael)
-C'est possible.
-Wouah il a triché c'est sûr !
-Il a beugué ! [chuchote]
[rires]
-C'est ouf !
-Merci Guillaume !
Et alors elle embrassait bien Caroline ?
-Ecoutes... C'était baveux. Tout bien quoi !
-Baveux à souhait !
-Je me sens très con !
J'ai l'impression d'être violé.
[rires]
-En plus, tu te verras dans la vidéo. Tu reverras les réactions de ton visage.
-Oui.
-Et tu verras derrière le mec qui fait... [imite des jumelles]
[rires]
-Il fait... [hochement de tête]
-Caroline ! [chuchotement]
[rires]
-C'est ça.
-Il est là, et il fait ça :
-K !
O !
-Ça va. Ça t'a plu ? Tu as déjà été mentalisé par quelqu'un ?
-Jamais. Non non.
-Et est-ce que ça te plait ça?
-Ah grave !
-Cool et bien comme ça, ça t'auras plu et moi j'ai kiffé ton spectacle donc on est des potes maintenant
G: Voilà !
On s'embrasse !
-Pas très chaleureusement quand même.
Je suis amoureux de toi !
[rires]
-Tu as vu comment moi j'ai flippé ?!
Mon réflexe de: AaaaH non !
-Ah mer** ça a trop marché !
-Cette blague va beaucoup trop loin je n'assume plus du tout !
Allez voir mon pote Guillaume. On peut aussi le voir sur Facebook et Twitter Guillaume Darnault et puis il a un site guillaumedarnault.fr.
Et surtout il joue ici tous les jeudis, du 18 février jusqu'au 23 juin 2016 aux Bo-Saint-Martin.
Ici c'est le Bo-Saint-Martin, il faut savoir qu'on est au Bo-Saint-Martin, qu'ils attendent que je me barre pour pouvoir fermer le théâtre.
Vous pouvez vous abonner en cliquant là haut.
Vous pouvez aussi laisser un petit commentaire parce que ça, ça me fait du... ça me fait plaisir en fait, c'est pour ça que je vous répond.
On a un objectif, vous avez vu 2500 abonnés on fait un live, un apéro en live tous ensemble.
Tu me dis oui genre : Oui oui... sûrement en fait...
Si il dit ça c'est vrai.
Vous pouvez venir me voir aux Hallucinations Collectives la prochaine c'est le 28 mars 2016 et en tournée avec le spectacle Fabien Olicard vous mentalise.
Ça fait beaucoup trop de promo d'un coup j'en ai bien conscience.
Et on est encore beaucoup trop proche.
Alors rendez vous demain à 17H pour le prochain Mental Vlog.
Ciao !